you are you got the special you're on
this tour it just seems like you know
from my perspective it seems like things
are going very very well for you okay
what's the problem no it's a problem no
it's good it's good this you know you
get specials and whatever whatever good
thing happens in your life it's tempered
with bad stuff you know right the way
life happen it did you just you're still
a person yeah you know what I mean it's
hard it's hard being a person it's been
hard yeah it's hard
you gotta constantly lie to yourself and
tell you that these things are important
so you don't kill yourself that's what
all that positive thinking is it's not
positive thinking it's lying to yourself
lying to yourself yeah you see those
Tony Robbins seminars you ever see that
guy like the positive thinking through
giant teeth thousands of people in a
Hilton Ballroom right on the moon this
Tuesday afternoon I'm great I'm great
no you're not yeah if you worried be at
work right now that's okay I get it you
got to make up these things and do it
you know I did look The Specials good
they put up billboards for me yeah I've
seen that and listen I think we have do
we have one of the billboards do we have
one or is it yeah I think we do there it
is
is that the one you're yeah that's it
yeah Tom Papa human mule and it's feels
like you kind of nailed what it's like
to be a dad right yeah and and the
perfect thing about this is it's all
about being a dad and then they put one
right on my way to school where I drop
the kids off and yeah I'm like if
they're like dad really do you have to
go this way again
I'm like it there's only one way to
school kids uh-huh there's your dad
again
yeah but again back to the how like good
things happen and the bad things having
the cat in that billboard the night that
the special came out dead weight is that
really your cat yes yeah that was my cat
dead okay it's all right it's not that
big a deal it's a no III didn't I didn't
like this cat very much
yes okay well look you like people right
you like some people some people you
don't like right uh this cat I tried to
like her she didn't like me and that's
how we lived yeah this cat for a while
this is yeah this was about young for a
cat this was about five six years but uh
it's not mine it's not my job as a dad
to like these animals it's alright I've
made people I've made to people and I'm
their leader I am their leader yeah so
it's my job when they want animals I go
get them animals I see these animals
twice I get them I Drive them home and
then when they're sick I Drive them out
that's unlike the warden on death row
you know they see me coming with the
carrier down the hallway they all get
nervous
who is he coming for right I don't know
Gracie's been walking kind of funny
there's one wise cat and her in her cell
with a harmonica don't pay him no mind
he'll come for all of us one day
I love little posit Armani so you took
this cat to the vet for the yeah the
next day I literally I drove it and look
it doesn't like me I don't like her and
you unzip the thing and we're in the
vet's office and she knows why she's
there I know why I'm there and neither
of us are happy yeah and the vet tells
us okay we're gonna give it one shot and
that's gonna mellow her out and then the
next shot that's gonna do it alright so
we'll leave you in here now to say your
good-byes
and you can't be like no I'm good just
get me that collar and I'm gonna beat it
oh okay right yeah you all love animals
here so I just start petting it and it's
probably looking at you like why padico
you never petted me before yeah it's
like hugging an uncle you never hugged
before that get off of me yeah and I'm
patting her and she's looking at me like
I'm gonna make you cry I'm like you're
not gonna make me cry
and then it starts like its final purr
he's like oh well you were kind of cool
you are with a family a long time just
as I broke down the vet walks in I'm
sobbing oh do you need more time no now
let's go let's go do this
you